[Música]
el ministro de interior francés gérard
hermanan calificó los ataques con arma
blanca registrados hoy en parís como un
acto de terrorismo islamista dos
personas resultaron heridas frente a la
antigua sede de la publicación satírica
saliendo y el principal sospechoso es un
joven paquistaní hay dos arrestados
tenemos reporte desde la capital
francesa
en plena campaña electoral de eeuu
superó los 7 millones de contagios por
kobe 19 donald trump visitó la florida
donde advirtió a los votantes latinos
que si su rival joe biden resulta electo
eeuu podría convertirse en la próxima
venezuela tenemos reporte desde miami
a pesar que perú se acerca a los 800 mil
contagios y a las 32 mil muertes por
kobe 19 el presidente martín vizcarra
anunció que la fase 4 de reactivación
económica iniciará de manera parcial en
octubre habrá retoma de vuelos
internacionales y del transporte por vía
férrea sin embargo no todas las
actividades previstas podrán abrir sus
puertas
bienvenidos a las noticias en france 24
mi nombre es alan austria
empezamos en francia donde un ataque con
arma blanca revivió los peores recuerdos
de los horrores en parís que vivió una
serie de masacres terroristas en 2015
los hechos se registraron justamente
frente a las antiguas instalaciones del
periódico satírico charlie hebdo y
coinciden con el juicio que tiene lugar
en este mismo momento contra posibles
cómplices de los ataques de hace cinco
años el hecho supone un acto de
terrorismo islamista según declaró el
ministro del interior francés hay dos
arrestados el autor principal del ataque
es un joven paquistaní de 18 años
nuestra periodista erika olavarría con
los detalles
se trata manifiestamente de un ataque
terrorista de tipo islamista así se
refirió el ministro del interior francés
ya la manada en una entrevista con la
televisión pública francesa al ataque
que tuvo lugar esta mañana en contra de
la antigua sede del periódico satírico
saliendo y en el que resultaron heridas
dos personas por arma blanca de hermanan
dijo que había preguntado también a los
prefectos si quizás no se había
subestimado la amenaza que pesaba en
contra de este lugar simbólico en
momentos en que tiene lugar en parís el
juicio por los atentados de enero del
año 2015 uno de los cuales afectó a la
revista satírica en el plano policial
una persona ha sido detenida como el
presunto autor de los ataques se trata
de un joven paquistaní de 18 años que
había llegado apenas hace tres años a
francia como un menor no acompañado en
agosto había cumplido su mayoría de edad
y aunque no tiene antecedentes por
radicalización si tiene antecedentes
policiales por porte de arma otra
persona fue detenido durante el ataque
un argelino de 33 años la policía está
tratando de establecer su vínculo con
los ataques y cinco personas fueron
detenidas durante la tarde cuando se
allanó el domicilio del presunto
en la zona de pantano esto es en el
noreste de parís el ataque en parís
coincidió con la intervención en la
asamblea general de naciones unidas del
primer ministro pakistaní imran khan
quien justamente se refirió a las
publicaciones de charlie hebdo como una
supuesta prueba de los continuos ataques
contra los musulmanes también arremetió
contra la india
you're in medical trees los musulmanes
continúan siendo atacados con impunidad
en muchos países
nuestros santuarios están siendo
destruidos nuestro profeta mahoma es
insultado el sagrado corán quemado todo
esto en el nombre de la libertad de
expresión incidentes en europa
incluyendo la republicación de
caricaturas blasfemas en charlie hebdo
son ejemplos de ellos
señor presidente el único país del mundo
y donde lamento decir que el estado
promueve la islamofobia es india
señor presidente para desviar la
atención de sus acciones ilegales y de
las atrocidades cometidas en la ocupada
región de jammú y cachemira india está
jugando un juego peligroso aumentando la
apuesta militar contra pakistán en un
entorno nuclearizado
eeuu superó el umbral de los 7 millones
de contagios
en este contexto avanza la campaña
presidencial donald trump se reunió con
votantes latinos de florida les dijo que
si su rival joe biden resulta electo
eeuu podría convertirse en la próxima a
venezuela
podríamos ser venezuela venezuela hace
15 años era un país muy rico muy muy
rico y próspero del que se hablaba en
todo el mundo uno de los más ricos de
hecho y parecía tener un tremendo futuro
y de repente optaron por una ideología
diferente
taiwán web de jeffrén agregado y edward
pones a las personas incorrectas a cargo
y bien podría ocurrir podría ocurrir muy
rápido pero ya perdí ley justamente en
ese evento en miami florida estuvo
nuestro corresponsal anthony belchí que
nos envió el siguiente informe
el presidente de donald trump ha
participado en un acto de campaña de la
organización en latinos for trump en
miami con este evento el mandatario
quiere asegurarse el voto de los
hispanos especialmente de los
venezolanos y los cubanos en florida un
estado clave y que podría ser decisivo
para las próximas elecciones los
asistentes la mayoría de ellos hispanos
han defendido las políticas de
transfobia e inmigración diciendo que es
necesario que haya una línea dura para
evitar la migración ilegal especialmente
en estos momentos en los que consideran
que se ha de preservar el empleo de los
estadounidenses tras la pandemia de el
coronavirus el candidato republicano ha
sacado pecho y ha asegurado que el país
está mejor que nunca en términos
económicos también para la comunidad
latina se ha vanagloriado del trabajo
que ha hecho desde el despacho oval
diciendo que él ha hecho mucho más en 4
años que yo byd en su contrincante
demócrata en 47 años en cargos públicos
con todo también ha mostrado el respaldo
a los pueblos de cuba nicaragua y
venezuela y se ha comprometido a seguir
trabajando para conseguir ha dicho que
esos países logren la libertad
habían muchos rumores de que el
presidente trump podría anunciar su
nominada a jueza de la corte suprema que
ya dijo que iba a ser una mujer pues
bien barbara lago a una cuba am en una
cubano americana de gran trayectoria
suena con mucha fuerza muchos expertos
avisan que su nominación podría ser un
guiño del mandatario a la comunidad
hispana nos vamos a perú donde el
presidente martín vizcarra anunció que
la fase 4 de reactivación económica
iniciará parcialmente en octubre se
abrirán vuelos internacionales solo a
países de la región a partir del día 5
de ese mes se aumentará a 50 por ciento
el aforo en restaurantes y el 60% en
tiendas comerciales
sin embargo bares cines y discotecas aún
no podrán operar a pesar de ello
epidemiólogos advierten que la
relajación de las medidas podría
conducir a un incremento de casos en el
sexto país con más contagios en el mundo
tenemos que estar preparados está en
nuestras manos
y seguir derrotando la pandemia hoy
nuestro sistema de salud está más
fortalecido que al inicio tienen ustedes
la firma con convicción de un gobierno
que seguirá trabajando incansablemente
hasta el último día sin distracciones
hasta controlar al virus y proteger la
vida de todas las familias peruanas
finalizamos en españa' y es que la
pandemia en madrid se complica ante el
repunte de contagios las autoridades
regionales anunciaron confinamientos en
ocho nuevas zonas sin embargo las
medidas son consideradas insuficientes
por el gobierno de españa que ha
asegurado que toda la ciudad se debe de
confinar veamos el informe de álvaro
cordero
la crisis sanitaria generó un
enfrentamiento entre la administración
central y la regional el gobierno
madrileño anunció que ampliaría las
restricciones a ocho zonas de salud más
de la capital una situación que mantiene
a madrid como el epicentro del rebrote
en españa' ya que concentra el 40 por
ciento de los casos a nivel general
recomendamos evitar todo un inti
necesario les puedo decir que 8 nuevas
zonas básicas de salud cumplen nuestros
requisitos por lo que en total serán 45
las áreas en las que se adoptarán las
medidas de control y prevención ya
conocidas la polémica ha llegado con la
contestación del ministro de sanidad
aunque las competencias de salud residen
en las regiones el ejecutivo central
defiende con final a toda la capital sin
excepciones las restricciones en madrid
comienzan cuando los sectores superan
los mil contagios por cada 100.000
habitantes pero el gobierno cree que
deberían comenzar con los 500 contagios
por cada 100.000 habitantes y yo creo
que las mismas semanas duras en madrid
así lo tengo que trasladar
también en otras partes del territorio
de españa y por tanto hay que actuar con
determinación y en tres palabras para
tomar el control y hay que decir esto no
hay otro atajo no hay otro atajo no vale
en esos momentos un cierto hay que un
cierto gradualismo hay que actuar con
determinación y esto es lo que el
gobierno de españa ha trasladado hoy a
los ciudadanos y zonas de la comunidad
de madrid y el conjunto del país la
polémica en torno a los confinamientos
parciales en madrid ha salpicado a su
presidenta isabel díaz ayuso ya que
numerosos sectores aseguran que
solamente se ha confinado a los
distritos más humildes a pesar de que
los datos de toda la capital son muy
negativos algo que generó numerosas
protestas
pues así llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a que siga con
nosotros en france24 ya que se cuide
cuídese mucho del cob y ticino
[Música]